Dwayne Johnson and the Marvel Cinematic
Universe seem like a natural fit for
each other and yet the rock has yet to
appear in an MCU movie so what gives
although it may seem strange that the
hottest star in Hollywood hasn't starred
in a Marvel movie there are a few
reasons that could explain why in 2014
it was announced that Julian Johnson
would be joining the DC EU portraying
the villainous black Adam in a Shazam
movie many were surprised that the rock
was playing a bad guy rather than a
superhero would the assumption being
that the larger-than-life actor would
prefer to be the star of his own DC EU
film those predictions ultimately proved
correct if you've seen Shazam which was
released in April 2019 and you know
Johnson is an innit that's because after
meeting with DC brass and 2017 to
discuss his role it was announced that
black Adam was getting his own solo
movie the film has no release date yet
but it's still very much in the works
and it's expected to start filming in
2020 the fact that Johnson will be
headlining a DC EU movie greatly reduces
his chances of doing the same for Marvel
because well it's pretty rare for actors
to star in films for both franchises and
when they do it's generally aside
characters moving from one franchise to
another in a bigger role remember when
Shazam Zachary Levi played Fandral and
two out of three Thor films we've yet to
see a lead actor switch teams but here's
hoping Johnson might be the first the
rock likes to refer to himself as the
hardest worker in the room and it's not
just a catchphrase the guy works all the
time take a look at his Instagram feed
which he updates constantly and you'll
see he's always either shooting a movie
or doing press for a movie the man just
moves from one project to the next
non-stop in 2018 he started in two
blockbusters with rampage and skyscraper
in 2019 he headlined fast and furious
presents Hobbs and Shah and Jumanji the
next level while also appearing and
fighting with my family whose production
he spearheaded what are your names good
my name it doesn't matter what your
names are you walk around here
interrupting the rock
like you haven't seen the Sun in 20
years you like to just stepped out of
Oliver Twist next year Johnson's got
Disney's Jungle Cruise and action comedy
red notice co-starring his DC EU
stablemate gal gadot he also stars on
HBO's ballers host a reality competition
he created called the Titan Games on NBC
and has quite a few films in various
stages of production plus he's active as
a producer on multiple movies he's
working on releasing a tequila and he's
helping design products for his project
rock collaboration with Under Armour
plus he's working out like a beast and
raising a family 2016 s People's Sexiest
Man Alive is busy with a capital B and
chances are good that he simply hasn't
had the time to work a Marvel movie into
his crazy schedule yet some actors just
looked tailor-made for their roles has
there ever been a more James Bond
looking James Bond than Pierce Brosnan
can you think of a more appropriate man
to play the mountain on Game of Thrones
than actual world Strongest Man Thor
Bernsen and when it comes to superheroes
who is more qualified to play one than
real-life superhuman to wane the rock
Johnson the rock has a physique that
looks like it was drawn by Rob Leah
fells so it seems like a no-brainer that
he should find himself a spot in the MCU
the only problem is Marvel prefers to go
with the unexpected when it comes to
their superhero casting when the studio
needed to cast star-lord the suave
leader of the guardians of the galaxy
they didn't go out and get Chris Pine or
James Marsden they went with Chris Pratt
who at the time was best known as a
somewhat schlubby sitcom actor they also
went with funny man Paul Rudd for
ant-man
relative unknowns Chris Hemsworth and
Tom Hiddleston for Thor and Loki
respectively and they cast the
supposedly washed-up over-the-hill and
problematic Robert Downey jr. as Iron
Man the guy who ended up leading the
entire franchise and although Marvel
sometimes does what's expected the
studio may think that casting the rock
as a superhero is a little too
on-the-nose for their brand as his level
of stardom has grown over the last
handful of years so has the rocks level
of influence in Hollywood seven bucks
Productions the studio Johnson founded
with his ex-wife Danny Garcia in 2012
has produced every single movie the
actor has starred in since 2017 s
Baywatch not only that but Johnson
wields a consid
durable amount of power over those films
he's very cautious about maintaining his
image and he's known to be pretty
inflexible when it comes to certain
aspects of his films for example he
forced a change to the ending of rampage
so the guerrilla wouldn't die at the end
plus he broke away from his role in The
Fast & Furious franchise to lead his own
spin-off Hobbs and Shaw no one tells me
what to do Johnson has shown that he
likes to be in control of his films and
if there's one studio that's not known
for giving up control
it's Marvel with the exception of the
spider-man movies which are produced in
coordination with Sony Pictures since
they owned the film rights to the
character Marvel Studios doesn't share
production credit with any other studio
the Studios President Kevin Feige has
the final say on everything in the MCU
and Johnson may not be willing to cede
the control he's become accustomed to
just for a spot in a Marvel movie in
spite of all the factors working against
the rock joining the MCU it still seems
like there may be something going on
between them that we just don't know
about yet at the 2019 MTV Movie Awards
Avengers and Game Director Anthony Russo
joked that Johnson should join the MCU
as himself but the most compelling piece
of evidence comes in the form of a
throwaway line Johnson included in a
congratulatory message he shared to
Instagram to celebrate end games box
office success the raw gushes about
Marvel in his three-minute video showing
nothing but love for the studio and
name-dropping a lot of people integral
to its success including nebula actress
and his quote Jumanji partner-in-crime
Karen Gillan but the biggest name drop
had to be Kevin Feige
the head honcho at Marvel Studios
Congrats and I know our assistants have
been trying to get us together for
dinner for months now we're both super
busy boys and I look forward to our
schedule linking up can you smell what
The Rock is cooking there if we had to
guess what these two busy boys would
talk about over dinner first on the
agenda would have to be the prospect of
Johnson joining Team Marvel just because
the rock hasn't appeared in the MCU yet
doesn't mean he's not going to
eventually after all someone's going to
have to play the thing when Fantastic
Four inevitably gets rebooted check out
one of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about your
favorite stuff are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]